c'est loana bon voilà je voulais vous
annoncer que si vous voulez un petit
message pour toutes occasions vous
pouvez contacter
me contactez moi surtout pour que je
puisse vous souhaitez ce que vous voulez
quand vous voulez vous voulez voilà vous
fait de gros bisous ou sinon vous avez
ma concurrente qui est derrière moi elle
va aussi vous faire quelque chose mais
je sais pas quoi
voilà alors loana c'est 60 euros elle a
le droit de le faire mais voilà après il
ya des fans qui sont énervés parce que
monet des dédicaces après un moment il
faut essayer de gagner sa croûte
le boulanger
et gilles verdez également gilbert dalla
trouver le profil de gilles verdez 40
euros pour une vidéo 30 euros
40 euros il ya castaldi 6,50 euros voilà
qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous dans
le cadre manhattan tout ça c'est bien
elle a besoin d'argent reçues c'est
compliqué dans le cas de benjamin c'est
un ami je répondais non
après moi l'histoire pardon les gens qui
font des boucles en boîte de nuit ton
métier c'est d'animer tient que de
cotinine dans une boîte de nuit dans un
grand magasin ou à la télé tu fais ton
métier mais quelque part dit dire à dire
quelque chose de gentil à quelqu'un
bonne anniversaire c'est comme si dans
la rue othman un autographe ou utiliser
est ce que tu peux faire une dédicace
est un ami des taux est payé comme ça
c'est plus ton métier ton métier c'est
pas d'être connue tome et essai et
animateur donc toi quand tu fais ça tu
pars du principe que ton métier ses
débuts connu gilles et quant au plus
jeune des grandes leçons à tout le monde
surtout et a pas besoin d'argent il me
semble hélas tous les soirs donc
finalement tu fais payer le fait que tu
es célèbre ta célébrité c'est un métier
gilles médous d'où ta célébrité c'est un
métier dur métier ses animateurs si je
peux me permettre je crois qu'il ne
t'aime pas
ça me choque allez on va qui ça choque
ça me choque d'illogique terriblement
mais je le dis agile et je le dis aussi
à benjamin même si c'est mon ami comme
moi je le dis aussi à benjamin c'est
choquant loana je suis comme mathieu que
loana son galère et qu'elles arrivent
des gens ils lui donnent 70 euros moi
c'est ok d'accord ok mais les deux ils
ont pas besoin de 50 euros de 40 euros
donc tu vas sur instagram combien nous
attend et je te rappelle
[Musique]
c'est très bien les faits vous allez sur
instagram vous demandez des messages aux
gens ils vont voulait faire moi y'a des
gens qui me demandent des vidéos sur un
stade comme j'ai que ça à [ __ ] je fais
des vidéos sur un stage en voix aux gens
je demande pas de 50 balles rondes pas
60 balles et je vais même te dire je le
demanderai jamais parce que ces gens à
qui vous demande ça c'est des gens qui
vous aiment énormément parlé donnant 60
balader avec comme vous on vraiment vous
aimez vous les uns même du beau jason
pas moi
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
je dirai pas le nom à calmer les
animateurs seront jusqu'à 10000 à 15000
euros avec une vidéo assez frugal 10000
et 15000 euros par mois parce qu'il ya
aussi des petits montants comme ça mais
quand c'est une entreprise par exemple
une entreprise qui le demande pour fêter
voilà c'est jusqu'à 1000 1500 euros
notre langue c'est chez les gros bras ne
pourra booking que tu prends et je sais
mon métier délit mais pardon mon métier
c'est pas des célèbres animateurs
à une olp paulin à noël pendant des mois
95 morts un hameau bana noël pendant les
fêtes les animateurs se font jusqu'à
10000 euros par mois dix mille euros par
mois pour vendre uniquement quoi leur
célébrité leur gentil ouest
géraldine également non alors oui alors
dans le cas de loana ou aimer cana
qu'ils ont raison c'est une question de
survie voilà alors évidemment raymond
pourrait dire ouais là cabossé faire un
métier après tout est normal comme
toujours mais il a dit qu'il était
d'accord par les douanes en fait voilà
c'est une question de jaude lors il a
besoin qu'on va lâcher pas là j'ai à
peine pour mes camarades je trouve que
c'est un peu moi je on peut être choqués
mais sains d'abord personne et dans la
vie privée des gens on sait pas quels
sont les besoins des gens après tout on
les connaît pas on n'est pas dans leurs
comptes en banque on est pas on sait pas
ce qui se passe dans leur vie moi je le
suis un peu
je peux comme leur papa vous savez on
l'est on les jette vite en pâture et de
ya aussi un cercle vertueux je crois que
parfois on peut faire ça et donner à des
associations à des bonnes causes et dans
ce cadre là moi je trouve que c'est
plutôt une bonne action alors gilles
verdez la réponse est à l'accusé je vais
répondre à la fois aux danseurs et
allegri
les grises le pardonne parce que sa
colère et sincère alors que le danseur
ces mobiles sont peu claires voilà ce
qui se passe et je suis très fier de
faire des rimes dans leur être rcx ans
parce que je donne cet argent depuis le
début c'est pour ça que je le fais à une
association mais tout tout tout dans mon
attention laissez moi finir je peux
donner le nom de l'association oui pas
100% réaliser c'est une association qui
s'appelle coulis maru au sénégal qui
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes en casamance vous donnez tous
j'ai donné un premier versement de tout
ce que j'avais gagné et là je récolte ce
que je gagne et je suis très fier
d'aller cet été leur donner la totalité
de ce que je vais gagner voilà
on vous donnait tout cet argent votre
coiffeur
intégralité aux restos du coeur donc
voilà après moi pour l'instant je vous
dise et rocket demande par m'a bien sûr
des demandes des anniversaires des des
encouragements des mets qui j'en ai plus
que toi les plus populaires il ya des
personnes qui sont à l'hôpital a surtout
plus à vos savoie cerd alarme aussi la
maison tellement lui montrer bon allez
je vous rassure je préfère honnêtement
je préfère faire ça que d'aller plupart
préfèrent aller dans une boîte sur un
bouquet très bien mais excuse moi tu
prends de capital pour faire deux choses
qui est très bien mais aussi pour signer
des des photos de les casser alors
qu'elle le chiffre d'affaires des photos
tout le monde mais moi j'ai pas
franchement moi en france il ya un vrai
tabou dès qu'ils gagnent de l'argent et
c'est toujours suspect en amérique elle
roule ses énormes stars qui font ça donc
voilà après franchement je préfère
donner 150 euros 200 euros par patient
reste ô allah est pas bon c'est très
bien il n'y a rien de scandaleux bon
après mais t'as pas besoin de ça
alors oui il faut le faire rien dire et
monte pas dans ma vie
je trouve que
[Rires]
c'est vrai dire c'est que ok c'est très
noble gilles mais c'est de donner de
l'argent en attendant cendres a déjà vu
ce
qu'on peut dire c'est ça la prochaine
fois que tu arrêtes dans la rue pour une
photo à nos demandes venir attaquer à la
photo n'a lancé 30 euros
ht cependant la petite gueule et de
holman nom des associations à qui tu
donnes de l'argent va c'est quand il
devient vulgaire il a d'ailleurs demandé
à social alors déjà je vous le dis je
les ai vus il a donné aussi la chc
association pour cyril hatt noir
je vais répondre puisqu'il met en cause
et comme si jamais les gens qui me
regardent le disent que c'est pour ils
pourront pas ce que c'est vrai je
téléthon chaque année voilà merci alex
émond et
sa gueule tu peux te remercie